love comes in all shapes
and I'm going to take a look at the ones
that happen to form shapes that I found
particularly pleasing
[Music]
that's an oddly worded
thing
never mind
we're doing it anyways we're moving on
so we are coming up on Valentine's Day
and as someone who is a little bit
notorious for having a hate on for
romantic subplots especially but romance
in general someone who deliberately left
romance out of their own novel and who
just in general tends to roll my eyes
whenever uh it comes up in stories that
are not billed to me as being first and
foremost romances
I probably give the impression of just
not liking love stories at all and
that's not necessarily true
I'm picky
demonstrably so but I like a good
romance too and I thought it would be
fun to share with you my picks for the
10 best romances in film now this is not
necessarily the 10 best romance stories
or romantic movies these are the
connections between characters that make
me go yeah
that's good stuff
and in some cases it is the main focus
of the story
in some cases it's not it's an aspect to
a story that's already going on
sometimes it's the lead character
sometimes it's uh actually some side
characters but these are romances and
connections and relationships that I see
in
warm my heart
because yes I too am not immune from the
fields so with that in mind let's count
them down
number 10
the Old Guard Nikki and Joe
the Old Guard was a Netflix movie from a
few years ago and it's about a group of
immortal characters well sort of
immortal they come back after being
killed but eventually someday they won't
and they never know when that's going to
happen but they live a long time and
they can have trouble making connections
some of them but two that don't
are Nikki and Joe
The Immortal lovers
their connection is wonderfully played
and it's just present
it's not a massive Focus the only time
it actually gets a highlight is when
they are captured and their captors
try and make them embarrassed or ashamed
and they won't have it your mocking is
thus infantile he's not my boyfriend
this man is more to me than you can
dream
he's the moon when I'm lost in darkness
and warmth when I shiver and cold and
his kiss still Thrills me even after a
millennium because their love is a love
across centuries and that alone
and validates whatever nonsense you want
to throw at them
they just love each other that much
persistently
and it's a beautiful thing to see and if
you ever get the chance to read any of
the Old Guard Comics it's delved into
even more there and that speech in the
van when they've been captured that's a
direct lift from the comic as well
they're great
number nine
When Harry Met Sally
there probably was never going to be a
lot of rom-coms on this list my own
favorite romantic comedy is Love
Actually but the thing is no one romance
that is present in that is one that I
would put as my favorite What I Like
About Love Actually is the culmination
of all things together and the way that
the stories play off of each other and
are cut to in between a lot of my love
of that is structural not the actual
narrative but this
this might be in my mind the perfect
romantic comedy
and a big part of that is because it
relies on something that way too many
romantic comedies gloss over because
it's pretty Universal in a romantic
comedy to have
some tension a bit of an adversarial
relationship at least initially between
your two leads because you know they
have to have something to overcome but
that tends to result in this General
notion that somehow not liking someone
means you actually like them and that's
just
a little odd how persistent that is but
you know what helps
time
acknowledging that if
somebody's feelings towards someone are
going to change
it's through truly getting to know them
and truly getting to know somebody
takes
time
there will be highs there will be lows
things will fall apart they may come
together again they may not
but that acknowledgment of the passage
of time and its impact on a relationship
for better and worse is part of why When
Harry Met Sally in addition to being
freaking hilarious
is a really wonderful Romance
number eight
[Music]
franchise Nick and Nora Charles
these two
are just made for each other
these are movies that I love anyway this
was a series of six films that are
mystery stories and Nick is a
theoretically retired detective and Nora
is his very wealthy wife he married into
money and they do love each other but he
married anybody which means he got to
retire and kick back and relax but of
course that's what Nora's life has
always been
and she rather likes the idea of a
little bit of Adventure and so she has a
tendency to encourage him to get
involved in situations where a body is
turned up and maybe the cops could use a
hand
the two of these bouncing off each other
they have the most adorable banter oh
wait ah drinks please into the kitchen
son
Grandma want large classes you have they
do wind each other up but there's never
anger there's never a hatred behind it
about the worst it ever is is just these
little faces of
at each other which is just cute
like there's a moment where Nora walks
in on Nick hugging another woman but and
she makes that face at him but that's
never a thing there's no fight there's
no misunderstanding nothing happens from
that
because she also she understands that he
was comforting her she knows he's not
gonna cheat on her they're not that kind
of dysfunctional
but they do banter and they do go back
and forth is that my drink over there
what are you drinking right
and they do wind each other up without
it hitting that level of toxicity that
is frighteningly common when you have
bantery couples
they're just adorable
number seven up
yeah
up
up is a movie primarily about grief and
about loss
and most people quote those opening five
minutes of up
as something that made them cry
but the reason it makes you cry
is because of how wonderful
the love between these two is
if that love wasn't sold so well
then it ending
in one of them passing
wouldn't break you and make you cry
but you do
because in
one lifelong Montage sequence
of showing a couple
spending a life together
not getting to do all the things that
they said they would
but still having something beautiful
that is masterful filmmaking
and there's so much heart in that
sequence that yeah it gets a spot in the
top ten
number six
The African Queen
going back to Classics again Humphrey
Bogart and Catherine Hepburn
this is a film in which we have two
characters who have very little in
common
stuck on this boat
traveling an African river
and this is also a bit of an adversarial
relationship and for very clear reasons
she is a woman of faith and he is a
drunk ship captain
but they find themselves together and
spending more time together
and driving each other nuts
and he goes too forward he gets drunk
and she pours out his liquor and he has
to get sober and he's bitter about that
fact
but not forever this is a case where you
could argue that the extenuating
circumstances of them just being stuck
together maybe pushes together people
who would not have gotten together
otherwise and there's certainly an
argument argument to be made that maybe
sometimes there's a reason they wouldn't
have gotten together or otherwise but I
think a movie like The African Queen
stands as an example of yeah but maybe
it's a good thing that these
circumstances did put them together
because as the story progresses and as
they move from adversarial to supportive
to caring
to loving that's something that maybe it
wouldn't have happened otherwise but
thank goodness it did
number five
bound
it's taken us a while to get to an
outright steamy example but yeah
bound is
oh
it's hard to talk about how hot this
movie is
um
Jennifer Tilly
and Gina Gershon
both bring so much Sexual Energy to the
Forefront but very different Sexual
Energy
Tilly is kind of
a cross between a femme fatale and a
trophy wife
Gershon is channeling James Dean as far
as I'm concerned the smolder
in her eyes
ah it pulls me over
and as these two get closer
and start to plot and to plan together
to find a way out of
the life that
neither of them wants and they come
together
and they bond in ways that I probably
would get demonetized for describing but
in a way that is nowhere nearly as male
gazy as you would expect huge shock this
movie turned out to have been directed
by two trans women all along we just
didn't know it at the time
ah
if you want a steamy
uh option out of this list
bound
number four Carol
also I would say arguably on the steamy
side but a bit more seductive than
outright erotic as bound was
but Carol is a story between two women
who find something that society says
they can't have and they know
that if they're found they won't be
allowed
to have
and it depends so much a story like this
on selling the chemistry between the two
leads
and this does
this does sell
that they are drawn to each other it
sells that initial interest possibly
even just lust
but it sells that deepening
and while I would hesitate to say that
this has a happy ending simply the fact
that it is not a tragic ending
given when the book it was based on was
released
that was a major milestone in queer
Romance
and this movie
I will take over Brokeback Mountain
though that wasn't consideration
consider that an honorable mention I
will take this over that any day
number three
the shape of water
and now we get
how we get to the weird stuff
Gamel Del Toro and his eye
for monsters for creatures and for the
ostracized and for recognizing what
would draw them to each other
this is a bonding
of two people that Society
has minimal use for a woman
who is mute
and is allowed to exist so long as she
is
unobtrusive and a creature
that the only reason it is not killed is
because of potential scientific
knowledge to be gained from it
there are very specific uses that the
society this takes place and has for
these two
and they're both very disposable
but they find each other
and they recognize
being othered
in each other they recognize how they
are on the outskirts of everything else
going on around them and they see that
commonality and it brings them closer
together
and in a way that goes places one would
not have expected a Best Picture Winner
to be
but there it is
and it's beautiful
number two
The Adams Family
I'm specifically going to cite the first
film The Addams Family because I feel
like it is the best iteration of the
relationship
between Morticia and Gomez Adams
it's still pretty decent and um Family
Values I don't like that movie as much
in general and I have I am in the
process of watching Wednesday a little
bit here and there as I have the time
and while there's a lot I like about
that show I don't really like uh Gomez
and Morticia especially
but here they're perfect
don't torture yourself Gomez
that's my job because everything about
them
is rooted
in not only love
but understanding they get each other in
a way that I'm not sure any other two
human beings in entertainment have ever
gotten each other
they know exactly who they are they know
exactly who this other person is and
they fit together to the point that they
might as well just be one person
and that's hard to do
because if you have two characters that
are too similar you often don't have a
good Dynamic you have a flat dynamic
because they're bringing the same energy
and while these two have very very
similar energy there's just enough
difference
between Gomez and more and Morticia him
with his more boyish energy her
able to match it sometimes but more
subdued quiet thoughtful
but both
so loving
so supportive of each other of their
family and both so
gosh darn kinky
red hot pokers later my dearest
seriously if you have not rewatched that
movie in a while
there's a lot of very clear implications
of the kind of stuff they get up to
and I dig it
and number one
is cheating my number one pick is
technically not a movie
it's technically a TV show
but first of all
it's from uh an anthology TV show so
it's a complete Standalone episode you
don't have to have seen any of the
others to watch it and have it work
beyond that it's my favorite romance in
entertainment period so I'm putting it
at the top of the list regardless and
three it's my list I can make the rules
I Can Break The Rules number one is San
Junipero
from Black Mirror
the
development of the relationship between
these two women
the way that they are drawn to each
other the baggage they each carry the
ways that they have to confront their
own damage
to ever have a chance at being together
at seeing
how the weight of what they carry might
stop them from ever being happy but then
seeing them overcome that
by the end I can't watch this and not
cry
and it's the best
kind of cry
that I will probably ever have
watching a piece of entertainment
it's it's a cop-out it's a cheat I don't
care San Junipero is so good I'm putting
it at the top even though this was
supposed to be a movie list
watch it if you haven't
you don't have to watch any of the rest
of Black Mirror and if you're worried
about how dark black mirror is this is
one of the lighter episodes still some
dark theming but like just watch it
it's so good it's so good what
those are my picks
what are yours what do you think are
some of the best romances not
necessarily romance movies but romances
the best relationships the best
connections the characters who fit best
together what do you think whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it patreon
pays the bills and is how I'm able to do
this as my living there are benefits for
supporting at any tier including usually
uh some degree of Early Access to these
videos
but even if you're not able to do that
like share subscribe help me out as well
but don't worry too much about that
because ultimately what I want you to
remember
is whether you are going to be with
someone on Valentine's Day or whether
you're single or whether you're going to
instead recognize it as Frederick
douglass's birthday and it's celebrated
on that basis which is actually what I
intend to do regardless of how you're
approaching it
you are beautiful
you are valid and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
and now my thanks to my highest
supporters on patreon Robin Moore zuman
lafulla Tarak the thing that goes doing
in the anime Oliver B Melinda Walters
emu delki Leo the Boyd Becky Sparks for
nabilax the poodle
Tracy Scrabble angry Casper Tim price
Adam RDL Taylor Shayla gourlay and
Russell and Bennett
thanks for your support
and if you want to get your name in the
credits check out the rewards on the
patreon
[Music]